>>> IT WAS THE MOST FULFILLING
TIME OF MY LIFE.
>> CREATED AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY
BASED ON COMPASSION AND SHARING.
>> THE AGENDA WAS FRANKLY TO
RAISE CONSCIOUSNESS, THAT WAS
HIS GOAL.
>> IT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
>> IT WAS ABOUT LOVE.
>> ME?
I DO IT FOR THE ASS.
>> THE PEOPLE OF OREGON WERE SO
BLINDED BY THEIR BIGOTRY THAT
THEY COULDN'T EVEN WITNESS THE
MIRACLE THAT WAS HAPPENING RIGHT
IN FRONT OF THEM.
>> I MEAN, THERE WAS ASS
EVERYWHERE!
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ALL
CAME FROM BUT I WISH THEY'D GO
BACK.
>> WE WEREN'T JUST GOING TO SIT
BACK AND LET SOME CULT MOVE IN
AND TAKE OVER OUR TOWN.
I MEAN, THIS WAS OUR HOME.
>> THEY WOULD DO THESE
MEDITATIONS.
EVERYBODY GETS BUTT NAKED AND
JUST STARTS WIGGLING THEIR
FLAPPY PARTS.
I PUT ON MY OLD ADIDAS TRACK
SUIT AND BLENDED IN WITH THOSE
HIPPIES ABOUT AND BEFORE I KNEW
IT I WAS KNEE-DEEP IN HAPPY ASS,
WHOO!
AND THOSE HIPS.
>> WHEN I SAW RAJNISH IN PERSON,
I WAS SO OVERCOME WITH JOY AND
EMOTION, I CRIED LIKE A BABY.
>> I SEE THIS LONG CARAVAN OF
CADILLACS ROLL UP AND I'M
THINKING, HM.
THAT MUST BE THE OJAYS OR
SOMEBODY.
THEN THIS BROTHER STEPS OUT
DRESSED IN ALL RED, AND
EVERYBODY FOLLOWING HIM IS
DRESSED IN ALL RED TOO.
AND I SAY TO MYSELF, OH, LORD,
HERE COME THE BLOODS!
>> HE WAS A CON MAN.
HE HAD THOSE PEOPLE BRAINWASHED.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT GUY.
>> HE WAS INCREDIBLE.
>> HE SPOKE WITH THIS
UNBELIEVABLE POWER.
>> SO MUCH GRACE.
>> MAN, I AIN'T UNDERSTAND A
DAMN WORD HE WAS SAYING.
I JUST KNOW 10,000 HORNY WHITE
WOMEN SHOWED UP IN TOWN WEAR
NO BRAS OVERNIGHT.
SO I TOLD MY OLD LADY, LOOK,
BABY.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO POT.
>> THE TOWN WAS A BUNCH OF TRASH
HICKS.
>> THEY ALL HAVE THIS WEIRD DEAD
LOOK IN THEIR EYES.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S DRUGS OR
SATANICS.
>> THERE WERE NO DRUGS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
>> I DO A LITTLE BUMP BEFORE I
LEFT THE HOUSE, THEN ANOTHER ONE
WHEN I WAS OUTSIDE THE HOUSE,
THEN ONE MORE BEFORE GOING BACK
IN THE HOUSE, BUT THAT WAS IT.
>> FREE LOVE WAS CERTAINLY PART
OF IT.
IT WAS ESSENTIAL TO OUR
SPIRITUAL JOURNEY.
>> OKAY, WHO WANTS TO [ BLEEP ]
SHEILA?
>> MAN, SHEILA WAS A FREAK.
SHE MADE ME HOTTER THAN
TRIGNOMETRY.
>> IT WAS WONDERFUL.
YOU COULD SMELL THE SEX FUNK FOR
MILES.
IT WAS SEX SMELLED LIKE A KARATE
CLASS FOR MONKEYS.
>> THEN IT ALL CHANGED.
>> A BOMB WENT OFF.
>> DEEP UNDER A HOTEL AND IT WAS
A DELIBERATE ATTACK.
>> IF I DIDN'T TAKE MEASURES TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY, NO ONE
ELSE WOULD DO IT.
>> WOULD YOU KILL FOR BAGWAN?
>> WHO'S BAGWAN?
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN, EVERYBODY'S
WANDERING AROUND WITH PISTOLS.
I KNEW Y'ALL WAS THE BLOODS.
DON'T GET ME CAUGHT UP IN THIS
MESS.
I LEFT BECAUSE OF THE CRIME
SITUATION.
I COMMITTED A BUNCH OF CRIME AND
IT BECAME A SITUATION.
>> IT'S A SHAME THE WESTERN
WORLD COULDN'T ACCEPT US.
>> WE WERE FREE.
>> WE WERE A RELIGION.
>> WE WAS THE BLOODS.
>> SHEILA, WHATEVER YOUR PLANS,
WE DON'T WANT THE ORANGE PEOPLE
IN OUR TOWN.
>> WHAT CAN I SAY?
TOUGH [ BLEEP ].
>> YOU ONE CRAZY-ASS PUERTO
RICAN LADY.